good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is Ingram angle from Washington
tonight delaying defeat that's the focus
of tonight's
angle there's no other way to say it it
was a clown show on Capitol Hill today
the same people who've been wrong about
pretty much every major foreign policy
issue for the past 25 years are back at
it again today blinkin and Austin
testified before Congress asking for
another $106 billion for multiple urgent
priorities Ukraine Israel something in
the Far East and humanitarian Aid to
Gaza they call it an emergency
supplemental but the real emergency is
in Biden's re-election Campaign which is
taking on more water than Biden's taking
naps stop supporting the genocide
and the people of Gaza shame on you all
the world is calling for a firee fire
now Cee fire
[Music]
[Applause]
now now this by the way went on and on
and on so much for that unbreakable
Biden Coalition now this is where most
normal people though are asking how it
makes any sense for the us to go further
into debt to pay for these emergencies
when we already have $33 trillion that
we're going to have to pay off and last
fiscal year a staggering $1.7 trillion
budget deficit this is their answer this
supplemental doesn't just help meet
today's urgent challenges it also
invests in our defense industrial base
when we send our friends Munitions from
our stock piles the money to replenish
our supplies strengthens our military
Readiness and we invest in American
industry and American workers okay okay
this is
mindblowing deplete our own stockpiles
by sending weapons to sadly a losing
cause in Ukraine then spend more money
to replenish the stock piles which will
help the defense
contractors they really do think you're
stupid well the things are going the way
things are going now in Ukraine we
should just have the Pentagon send
weapons directly to Russia because
they're going to end up taking them
eventually anyway just like they did of
course the Taliban and
Afghanistan now the fact is even the
staunchest warhawks can no longer make a
persuasive case for Ukraine this is the
main reason by the way why they want to
combine the
61.4 billion request for Ukraine with
the funding request for legitimate
reasons like Israel and
elsewhere why is it so important that we
provide supplemental funding for Ukraine
the indopacific and humanitarian
assistant in addition to military aid to
Israel the defense industrial base
operates in a complex way um it's an
interdependent unit making these
Investments together allows us to do
what's needed to strengthen the defense
industrial base and to seize the
benefits and efficiencies that come from
making these Investments
together it's words signifying nothing
it's more efficient he says to get all
this money at one time I bet it is now
the truth is they don't want Senators
like Joe Mansion or John tester who are
facing really tough reelection bids to
be forced to vote on a Ukraine
Standalone if the Biden team was serious
about our defense industrial Base by the
way they wouldn't be sucking up to China
whose entire goal is to undermine our
industrial base oh and don't forget
president X is on Putin's side in
Ukraine the pair was together enjoying a
romantic evening each other's company
and in Beijing just a few weeks
ago the fact is the Pentagon wants a Us
credit card with no limits and no
accountability the Department of Defense
is the only Federal agency that has
never in the history of ever been
audited but your Inspector General
insisted that he be in charge do you not
see the irony there with respect to
Ukraine Senator I'm confident our
Inspector General will do uh
a great job in uh in uh making sure that
we that we remain on track with our
responsibilities in in
Ukraine of course No One Believes that I
don't think even Austin believes that a
blockbuster piece I mentioned briefly
last night in time laid bare the
corruption in Ukraine and the lack of
accountability for the billions mostly
from America that is poured into Ukraine
a top presidential adviser to zalinski
telling a report named Simon Schuster
that people are stealing like there's no
tomorrow zalinsky fired most of his
cabinet including his defense minister
earlier this year you may remember but
he was never forthcoming was he about
the reasons for that shakeup more from
the time article the president was
warned in February that corruption had
grown Rife inside the defense Ministry
but he dithered for more than six months
giving his allies multiple chances to
deal with the problem quietly or explain
them away that zalinsky is a crafty one
no wonder the administration wants no
real tracking of the hundred billion
dollars we've already sent corruption in
Ukraine is rampant and that's terrible
for Biden who knows a thing or two about
corruption as is the New Revelations
that Ukraine has a full full-blown
recruitment crisis on its hands here's
more from the time investigation in some
branches of the Ukraine military the
shortage of personnel has become even
more dire than the deficit in arms and
ammunition one of zelinsky's close AIDS
tells me that even if the US and its
allies come through with all the weapons
they've pledged we don't have the men to
use
them okay which begs the question why is
Biden doubling down there to rebuild and
reimagine Ukraine's infrastructure
that's why this funding will not only re
rebuild Ukraine's economy and offset the
damage rough by Russia but it will also
help to reimagine it investing in new
Industries infrastructure and Supply
chains connected to Europe and to the
world secure and resilient clean energy
anti-corruption bodies Civil
Society is this a green news zinsky deal
but all of this the Democracy building
it all sounds familiar the same types of
arguments that were made for Iraq and
Afghanistan we got to stop the Taliban
or girls aren't going to be able to
attend school well how did that all work
out democracy building in
Iraq the truth is they have no defined
strategy to save Ukraine or defeat
Russia the summer offensive was supposed
to be the answer but it didn't work and
there's no plan B they also don't want
Joe Biden to face a humiliating defeat
on the global stage when he's up for
re-election this massive sum of money
that they want now for Ukraine tied to
legitimate aid for Israel is a cynical
and widely irresponsible political Ploy
delaying defeat in Ukraine to secure
Biden's victory in
2024 and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else